بعيون على الحدود يستقبل الرئيس الاوكراني
مسؤولين اوروبيين في العاصمه على راس
القادمين الى هنا رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ومسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يركز الرئيس الاوكراني
في حديثه مع الاوروبيين على التخوفات من
حشود عسكريه روسيه على الحدود الشرقيه
الشماليه وفي المناطق الجنوبيه وفق مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني فان القوات
الروسيه تستعد لشن هجوم واسع خلال
الاسابيع القليله القادمه سيعيد الروس
مشهد بدايه الحرب ويبداون هجوما من الشرق
والشمالي والجنوب حينها وصلت القوات
الروسيه الى مشارف العاصمه بدات زحفا
يستهدف كييف من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه
وسيطرت على مساحات واسعه في الجنوب والشرق
اليوم يقول وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه استدعت قرابه نصف مليون
جندي من الاحتياط وليس 300 الف كما اعلن
سابقا بشكل رسمي يب من القلق الاوكراني له
ما يدعمه في الشمال تقول وزاره الدفاع
البيلاروسيه انها باتت تملك صواريخ اسكندر
القادره على تنفيذ اي مهمه عسكريه هذا
بالاضافه الى منظومات صاروخيه تضرب الى
مدن يصل الى 300 كيلومتر مئات الكيلومترات
هذه تعني تغطيه نصف الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تقريبا بصواريخ من بيلاروسيا هذه
التصريحات تاتي بعد اختتام مناورات روسيه
بلا روسيه انتهت قبل ايام قليله قرب
الحدود بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا وفق
المخابرات الاوكرانيه فقد شهد البحر
الاسود كذلك تغييرات في نشاط القوات
الروسيه يزيد النشاط الروسي وتتحرك حاملات
الصواريخ على بعد 500 كيلومتر عن العاصمه
كييف وبالتالي تغطيه كل المناطق
الاوكرانيه تقريبا بالصواريخ الروسيه
هذه التخوفات والحشود تعكس الوضع
الميدانيه المتعثره للطرفين
لا يستطيع اي من الجيشين حسب تقدمه على
الجبهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه وتحديدا لوجانز
كودونيتسك يتوقف الروس عند محور ويعجزون
عن التقدم اكثر للسيطره على ما تبقى من
اقليم
ويتوقف الاوكرانيون كذلك ويعجزون عن
استعاده السيطره على مزيد من المساحات في
الاقليم او التقدم اكثر نحو هكذا يترقب
الطرفان خطط كل منهما وتحضيراته للاسابيع
القادمه تنتظر هي الهجوم الروسيا واسعا
وتنتظر موسكو ما قد يقدمه الغرب من دعم
الليكييف يقلب المعادله